So we've said a number of times that traditional feedstocks are petroleum based,
that we understand that there are issues with petroleum based feed stocks in
terms of uh,
depletion,
finite resource,
uh,
many of them are linked to particular types of toxics and,
that are inherent in those feedstocks.
And there's a significant,
uh,
area of development in green chemistry around the use of renewable feedstocks,
alternative feedstocks that,
uh,
that might be,
um,
might not have the same challenges as petroleum.
Right.
So what I'd like to do is just show you a few things at the,
at the cutting ends that have been really accomplished,
uh,
and recognized through the presidential green chemistry challenge and woods and
Richard Wall is a professor down at the University of Delaware.
Um,
anybody here at blue hen.
Okay.
The University of Delaware.
And He,
he's,
uh,
we've collaborated with a professor will on a number of things,
but he is just a tremendously creative chemical engineer.
And one of the things that he's developed as a whole new series of composites,
uh,
biobase composite and you see it's derived from,
everything from,
uh,
flax,
vegetable oils,
lignin cellulose and chicken feathers,
chicken feathers,
really chicken feathers.
So one of the things that,
uh,
he's,
he's designed these composites for wide ranges of,
of materials,
a wide range of applications.
For instance,
um,
has he put these composites into hurricane resistant housing and had the
demonstrated out it down after Katrina?
Yes.
Has he used these composites for a large wind turbines,
uh,
that,
that need the kind of strength and flexibility,
uh,
that are about a football field long,
some of these giant propellers?
Yes,
but the one that I actually really like is when he
put it in a,
and used it as a replacement for alternative feedstock for a silicon chip.
And let's say you're making computer chips out of chicken feathers.
And he said,
yeah,
because the,
the nano structures and the sizing of the chicken feathers actually had at the
time it was conducted a higher clock speed than the,
than the Intel chip that it was replacing.
Uh,
so it is not,
we always returned to this.
It's not just about using green chemistry or alternative material to do things
that either the same or a little bit worse and you have to sacrifice.
It's how do you get higher performance by,
uh,
by using these alternative processes.
So yes,
does it consume less water and energy and produce less ways to,
yeah,
but it's about the performance of these new composites.
I should say that all of these that I'm going to be discussing today are able to
be found on the Presidential Green Chemistry Challenge Award website run by the
EPA.
All right.
Then there's Jeffcoat another,
um,
good green chemist who was recognized and he's made a whole series of,
of new,
of new polymers.
Um,
his feedstock is carbon dioxide.
Okay.
So,
uh,
we know that a polycarbonate cross,
his name a carbonate,
uh,
has CO2 and its and its backbone.
So he is found ways of uh,
and Torical elating reacting and getting the CEO to,
uh,
could also do it with carbon monoxide because of the of the catalyst that he's,
these invented to,
to be in Turkey lived there.
So why do,
why do we care about this?
Why is it,
why is this such a good thing too to use co two as a feed stock for polymers,
that's plenty of CO2.
So here's the thing,
a lot of chemical products,
our feed stock driven the major part of the cost for a wide range of especially
high volume,
um,
materials,
the cost of fee,
the feedstock is what's going to drive the price of the product and many,
many different types of commodity products.
So if you take something that is not only a waste,
so maybe it's a,
maybe it's zero,
zero cost,
but now people are paying to get rid of erotic to capture it,
etc.
Etc.
Then all of a sudden that becomes a really good economic equation.
Now it's easy to start asking.
The cast came and questions of,
well,
how do you get that feed stock?
Is it really coming out as pure Sio two or do I have to separate it from other
gasses and what kind of energy do I have?
So there's a lot of questions that need to be honest.
Bioamber um,
this is,
uh,
another,
ability to make a bio based material feedstock to make succinic acid.
Succinic acid is because it's one of those so called platform chemicals that
that uh,
a lot of people might not care about succinic acid itself,
but instead it's a,
it's what you can make from,
uh,
six,
six succinic acid.
They talk about,
um,
uh,
not even a gen genetically engineering or making things from,
from bio organism.
This is a modified eco eco like catalyst.
Uh,
we could go into a lot of the fact that,
oh,
most of these biobased processes are taking place in,
in water rather than using organic solvents and all of the issues associated
with that.
Um,
but I wanted to point out that,
uh,
this method for producing 600 gas costs 40% less than the traditional petroleum
based food and consume 60% less energy.
Okay.
Again,
you're going to hear me say this a thousand times until you've driven crazy
green chemistry cannot,
must not be a,
well,
it's going to cost you a little lid more and it's going to perform a little bit
less.
This needs to always show those,
um,
those advantages.
Genomatica another example of a building block chemical.
This is um,
this chemical is essential to the Olympics.
Why is it essential?
The Olympics could not be held today without BDO.
Why?
Cause it's used in making spandex.
The Olympics can be held without spanned x.
We know that I watch the Winter Olympics,
I see speed skating.
Um,
anyhow,
I also wanted to point out again,
consumed 60% less energy and has a 70% a smaller carbon footprint and the cost
is projected to be 15 to 30% less than the petroleum based manufacturer.
I just toss this one in there.
Maybe because,
uh,
instead of just talking about chemical building blocks,
here's an example of Patel hotel that is making a printer toner.
Uh,
so he's saying,
Oh,
do they make any consumer products?
Yeah.
So here at silver printer toner,
who knew that 400 million pounds of printer toner we used,
uh,
every year I showed him.
But if it gets 25% market penetration,
uh,
it's looking at 360,000 tons of co two reduction,
a year.
Um,
this is not only a naturally base pesticide,
but it's also a thousand times less toxic to humans and 44 times less toxic.
Then the two common pesticides that are used,
uh,
currently,
and it's effective at 10 to 34 times smaller,
uh,
application,
rate and is expected to replace 1.8 million pounds of organophosphates.